[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نحييكم
مشاهدينا الى بانوراما سنخصصها اليوم كذلك
لمتابعه التطورات الانتخابات نتحدث طبعا
في تركيا وهذه هي العناوين سؤال
للمره الاولى في تاريخها تركيا تحسم
السباق الرئاسي بجوله اعاده بين
اردوغانو لمن سيصوت الاطراف في ال 28 من
مايو
هاي اتفاق الى
اتفاق لاطر
صاحب الترتيب الثالث في الانتخابات
التركيه يضع شروطها على طويله المفاوضات
مع خصميه السابقين فكيف سيلعب دور صانع
الملوك كما يسمى في جوله الاعاده
ونحييكم الى نقاش الملف الاول لاول مره في
تاريخ تركيا تقرر لغه الارقام والحسابات
تاجيل اسم رئيس التركي الجديد الى 28 من
مايو الجاري عبر جوله ثانيه وحاسمه الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان الذي يحكم بلاده منذ 20
عاما تقدم على منافسه الرئيسي كليتش لكنه
لم يحصد الاصوات اللازمه لتحقيق فوز صريح
المجلس الاعلى للانتخابات في تركيا اكد
تاجيل حسم السباق الى جوله اعاده موضحا ان
اردوغان حصل على
49.51 بالمئه من الاصوات
وبانو حصل على
44.88% مضيفا ان كلا المرشحين يمكنهما بدء
الدعايه الانتخابيه على الفور وفقا
للنتائج خساره اردوغان كانت واضحه في اهم
مقاطاعتين وهما اسطنبول وانقره بعد فوز
كيليتش دور اوغلو فيه ما بفارقا ضئيل كذلك
تمكن الاخير من السيطره على جميع
المقاطعات في شرق تركيا تقريبا وبعض
الولايات في الجنوب الغربي هذا واظهرت
نتائج الانتخابات ان حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكمه الذي يتزعمه اردوغان سيحتفظ ايضا
باغلبيه في البرلمان المؤلف من 600 مقعد
ابرز مقاعد البرلمان التركي حزب العداله
والتنميه عام
20185 مقعدا عام 2023 تراجع الى 267 مقعده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 2018 حجم 146
مقعدا عام 2023 زادت حصته الى 169 مقعده
حزب الحركه القوميه عام 2018 حازت 49
مقعدا عام 2023 حاز 50 مقعده الحزب الجيد
عام 2018 حاز 43 مقعده عام 2023 حاز 44
مقعدا حزب اليسار الاخضر عام 2018 حاسس 67
مقعدا عام 2023 تراجع الى 61 مقعدا
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
جواب المحلل السياسي من اسطنبول كذلك
دكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو الباحث في شان
التركي والعلاقه الدوليه من باريس الدكتور
خلدون النبواني الباحث السياسي ومن واشنطن
الدكتور وليد فارس الخبير في السياسه
الخارجيه الامريكيه اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام
دكتور خلدون وكذلك دكتور وليد اسمحوا لنا
ان نبدا اولا بضيفانا من اسطنبول حتى نخصص
هذا الجزء الاول لنقاش تركي تركي في قراءه
لهذه النتائج وسابدا معك سيد جواد سيد
جواد في قراءه لنتائج هذه الانتخابات
ما المفاجئه ان كانت هناك مفاجاه حدثت
بمعنى اذا تمعنا في نتائج الاكيد بان
اردوغان حصل على النسبه الاعلى ولكن من
حيث
القدره على اولا الاقناع وثانيا على كسب
الاصوات الغير منتظره هل فاز اردوغان ام
كلش
تحيه لك ولضيفينا لمشاهدين الكرام طبعا
كانت مفاجاه للجميع خاصه للصفوف المعارضه
لانه مع هذه الازمات الكبرى من غلاء
الاسعار تضخم المفاجئ
ملف الزلزال
غير ناجحه
ملفات الخارجيه الفاشله
وايضا الفساد المالي الذي
وجهت اليه بقوه وايضا بعد عقدين من زمان
وحكومه تعبانه ولا توجد يوجد برنامج
اقتصادي عندهم وغير ذلك نرى انه المعارضه
لم تستفيد ابدا من هذه الاسباب بقوه صحيح
انه لم يصل رئيس اردوغان الى خمسين بالمئه
وتراجع من هذه الجهه موجود تراجع شعبيتي
لا زال موجودا لكن بصراحه المعارضه باتت
ضعيفا يعني لم يقدموا شخصيه جديده نفس
شديد طاقه جديده
تنحت للناخبين حتى يجلب اصواتهم
يعترفون بالفشل في فيما بينهم لكن امام
الاعلام يقولون بعد اسبوع سوف ناتي بقوه
طبعا اسبوعين مده طويله جدا في السياسه
ننتظر
التحركات واكثر ان يشتغلون لاقناع الشعب
التركي نعم الدكتور مهند ما رايك في هذا
الكلام ضيف يقول بان المشكله ليست في
اردوغان الذي فاز وانما المعارضه الذي
التي لم تقدم شخصيه قادره على الفوز رغم
ان البعض يقول بان 44% مقابل 49 لاردوغان
هي نسبه جيده
وجميع المشاهدين الكرام هذه الانتخابات
انتخابات المفاجاه ليست على المفاجاه على
مستوى الارقام بل على مستوى الطموحات يعني
اريد ان نبدا في هذا التمهيد لاصل وليعلق
على كلام ضيفك
المفاجاه كانت على مستوى الطموحات صعودا
او هبوطا يعني كان اقصى طموحاته وسقف
طموحاته ان يصل الى ثلاثه بالمئه وقد
تجاوز الخمسه بالمئه رئيس اردوغان كانت
طموحاته بان ينهي الامر من الجوله الاولى
بسرعه ولا يحتاج الى انتهاء عدل افراز
واصوات الخارج لكي ربما يكسب الجوله
الاولى وينهي الامر كانت هذه ايضا مفاجاه
المفاجاه الثالثه والكبيره والتي بني بها
التحالف السداسي والتي كانت بالفعل تشبه
ما تكون
بالصدمه السياسيه والاحباط الكبير
للقاعده الشعبيه لاولئك الاحزاب السته او
السبعه وهي ان
كانوا يتوقعون على الاقل ان لم يكونوا
يتجاوزون رئيس اردوغان انما يكون قد يكون
الارقام متقاربه بحيث لا تتجاوز النقطتين
ولكن ها يتجاوزت الخمس نقاط اذا
الانتخابات هذه المفاجئه الان خطا
المعارضه هو اشبه بخطا الملغم الخطا الاول
هو الاخير يعني اختيار شخصيه خسرت امام
الرئيس اردوغان احد عشر مرات وبالرغم من
كبر سنه عدم وجود كاريزما حقيقيه الرئيس
اردوغان لا ننسى يعني شيء او ابينا عشرين
عاما او يضعها او جعل هناك انطباعا في
عقول وقلوب الشعب التركي بشخصيه معينه
نموذج للقائد الرئيس معين هذا كان يجب ان
يكون هناك مرشحا يجاريه على الاقل او
يتقاطع مهو معه لكي يكون هناك ارتياح نفسي
فضلا عن القناعه العقليه ولكن هذا لم يحدث
هذا ربما كانت السيده اكشنر اكثر حصافه وا
بعد نظرا من الرجال الخمسه في الطاوله
السداسيه عندما كانت رافضه لان يكون هو
المرشح وكانت تريد اكرم امام اوغلو ولو
كان
لكانت الامور مختلفه تماما وكان المشهد
الانتخابي في تركيا
والحديث كان سوف يكون في مرحله مختلف
تماما ولكن ديكتاتوريه
كمال كريستار الذي اصر ان يكون هو المرشح
واجبر اكشنر على العوده الى الطاوله وابعد
اكرم امام اوغلو منصور ان يكونان مرشحان
للرئاسه وينادي ويقول لك التركي اشتاقت
الديمقراطيه واشتاقت الحريه وهو ديكتاتور
فيما بين احزابه وما بين تحالفه وبالتالي
هذا الامر انعكس سلبا على الناخب للدعم
كان للمعارضه وسوف يعكس ينعكس ذلك بشكل
كبير متى حضرتك
بالديكتاتور كمال كلتش دار اوغلو ما رايك
في هذا التوصيف سيد جواد خاصه وان البعض
على نقيص ما يتفضل به الدكتور مهند يقول
بانه كلتش دار اوغلو رغم انه فرض اسمها
على طاوله السداسي السياسي الا انه كذلك
من جهه اخرى منفتح على ملفات اخرى اغلقها
اردوغان في فترات معينه
اذا يصفه هو كمال كريستال اوغلو بانه
ديكتاتور فكيف يصف الرئيس اردوغان
يعني يعني لنكون بالمنصفين في
دكتور مهند سؤال حضرتك يمكن ان تجيب عليه
يقول لك ان كنتصف
كيف ستصف اردوغان
اصف اردوغان بانه احتكم للصندوق ولم
يستخدم المليونين ونصف مليون صوت لمصلحته
ويستغلها ويعلنها انني الرئيس ولا يمكن
لكم ان يحصل على مليونين ونصف صوت بعد
الان والامور حسمت وفرض امر الواقع بحكم
هذه الملايين التي هي في
لا يمكن ان نصف رئيس صندوق اردوغان كان
هذا تعليقك باغتطاب خليني اعود للاستاذ
جواد اتفضل
نعم هناك خلافات في داخل حزب الشعب
الجمهوري بين
العلمانيين المتشددين من المدن الغربيه
وبين الاكراد والعلويين من المدن الشرقيه
هذا الخلاف دائما موجود في داخل الحزب
والان كما الكوليسترول هو المسيطر على
الحزب بشكل او اخر لكن اذا يخسر هو في
الجوله الثانيه
بنفسه هو باراده شخصه سوف يستقيل من رئاسه
الحزب ثم ينتقل الى
متقاعد فالحزب سوف يجتمع ويختارون شخصا
جديدا لكن في في
المقابل نرى انه في حريه الصحافه فقط في
بلدنا
فيما بين 180 بلد نحن في رتبه 160
فلا يقدرون الصحفيون يظهرون على شاشات ما
ينتقدون بالسهوله ونعرف قضايا الحريات
فكيف صار القضاء مسيس وغير ذلك لكن بصراحه
هناك اراده التغيير في داخل المعارضه ايضا
موجوده علما انه لا بد ان تكون يكون هناك
تغيير
بالنتيجه ايضا المعارضه عليها ام تقدم
برامج وشخصيات جديده قابله للمنافسه
لا يمكن لنا ان نقول مثلا لا يوجد شخص
يواجه اردوغان لا تتحدث عن انا المعارضه
يجب ان تقدم منافس قادر على ان يفوز وكانك
تتحدث بنفس مهزومه وكان الجوله الثانيه
ستكون حتما لاردوغان هذا ما نفهمه على
الاقل من خلال كلام حضرتك
نعم انا اقول بصراحه عبر قناتكم الكلمه
سنان اوغان هو من اقربائي وانا اعرف كيفيه
تعامله مع الاخرين هو سوف يظهر لكم بعد
ايام انه اتفقا مع رئيس اردوغان بصراحه
لكن هل الذين صوتوا لصالحه هل هم
يتابعونه وياتمرون باوامره عندما اشار الى
التعاون مع اي جهه من الجهتين انا لا اظن
ذلك لانه جديد الوجه في السياسه التركيه
لكن مستقبله مشرق جدا
وسوف يكون رئيسا
للطائفه القوميين المتطرفين هنا في تركيا
ولا زالت مع الاسف الشديد القوميه تزداد
بمواقف الحكومه الخاطئه تجاه اللاجئين
تجاه اشقائنا العربي تجاه الاخرين مع
الاسف صارت القوميين هم الرمى الفائزون في
هذه المره من الانتخابات لا اردوغان بلا
كمال حضرتك على اوغان ورغم تاكيد حضرتك
على اهميته طبعا نحن سنعود له وسنناقش هذا
الموضوع ولكن اسمحوا لي ان نذكر بما قالها
فيما يخص الجوله الثانيه لانه تحدث بحماس
شديد وقال بانه سنقاتل او ساقاتل حتى
انتصر او الى اخر رمق سنتذكر مقاله ومن ثم
اعود لك دكتور مهند
الله
دكتور مهند هذه التصريحات تصريحات حماسيه
ونحن نتحدث عن نسبه تحصل عليها محترمه جدا
44,1 وبالتالي هل يمكن ان تكون هناك
مفاجات كذلك في هذه الجوله الثانيه
لا يبدو لي وهذه التصريحات تنم عن اقرار
ضمني بالخساره ما هي الا رسائل يحاول ان
يوصلها لقاعدته ولاحزابه الذين اوكلوه بان
يكون هو المنافس للرئيس اردوغان واننا سوف
ننتصر
سوف يستيقظ الاتراك على انك مايكل هو
رئيسا لتركيا وبدا يتحدثون حتى عن
الخروقات في بعض فرز الاصوات وما شابه هذا
التردد وهذا الخطاب لا يقبله الشارع
التركي باي حال من الاحوال ويعلم تماما
وهو خبير ممرت على تركيا
اصناف متعدده من الرؤساء ومن الخطابات
وبخبره الشعب التركي يدرك تماما ان هذا
خطاب خطاب انهزامي وان كان بصوت مرتفع على
كل سنتقدم قليلا في النقاش الحديث عما
ينتظر تركي كذلك في الفتره القادمه وعلى
حسابات كذلك الرئيس ولكن سنتوقف مع فاصل
ساعود لكم بعد قليل ضيوفي الكرام لنفهم
اكثر هذه التطورات كذلك مع الدكتور خلدون
والدكتور فارس بعد قليل والى فاصل
مشاهدينا ومن بعد سنعودين نتابع
صاحب الترتيب الثالث في الانتخابات
التركيه يضع شروطه على طاوله المفاوضات مع
خصميه السابقين فكيف سيلعب دور صانع
الملوك كما يسمى في جوله الاعاده
[موسيقى]
التفاوض مع اردوغان وكليتش دار اوغلو لدعم
احدهما في الجوله الثانيه من الانتخابات
نتائج الانتخابات بمرشملها ومرحله
الانتظار التي دخلتها تركيا تكشف وفق
رويترز انقساما عميقا في المجتمع التركي
الذي يشهد مفترق طرق سياسيه ونقلت رويترز
عن خبراء اتراك احتماليه ان يمنح الوقت
المنتظر لحين عقد الجوله الثانيه وقتا
كافيا لاردوغان لاعاده تجميع صفوفه
الانتخابات التركيه المرشح الخاسر يحدد
هويه رئيس تركيا
اردوغان وكليتش دار اوغلو الى مرحله
الاعاده
[موسيقى]
اما ثالثهما اوغان يقول ان محاربه الارهاب
واعاده اللاجئين خطوط حمر ومحتمل ان يدعمك
لتشدار اوغلو في جوله الاعاده ما لم يتم
تقديم تنازلات للحزب المؤيدي للاكراد
يعرض
خمسه.2% هي نسبه اصوات ناخبيه لمنحها لاحد
المرشحين لجوله الاعاده
ساكون منفتحا للتفاوض على اساس مبادئهما
[موسيقى]
يقول بانه سيتفاوض مع الجانبين على اساس
المبادئ وليس المكاسب ولكنك منذ قليل
استاذ جواد قلت بانه عن معرفه بشخص تتوقع
انه سيصوت اوسع يدفع
مؤيديه للتصويت لاردوغان دكتور مهند هل
تعتقد بان سننو جان سيدعم اردوغان في
المرحله المقبله وان قال بان المبادئ
ستتفوق على المكاسب ما المبادئ التي يمكن
ان يلتقي بها او من خلالها مع اردوغان
سؤال في غايه العمق وربما يبدو لي هناك
لدي طرحا مختلفا عما هو متداول بان
التحالف الجمهور والتحالف الشعب اي اقصد
هنا اردوغان وكمان ومن خلفهم ومن خلفهم
وكانهما يبحثان عن هذا الجوكر الانتخابي
ليكسبان المعركه الانتخابيه واحتمال الامر
انا ارى الامر واقرا الامر بطريقه مختلفه
يبدو لي ان سنانه ينتظر بل ويتلهف ويتشوق
لان يطلب منه تحالف الجمهور بقياده الرئيس
اردوغان ان يطلب منه اعطاء اصوات التي
قدمت له او نصفها له هذا امنيته الكبيره
ولكن لا يبدو لي بحكم تمارسنا بالرئيس
اردوغان ومعرفتنا بشخصيته
وبطريقه تفكيري وشخصيته القويه العنيده هو
يريد ان يكون رئيسا بالرقم الثالث عشر
لجمهوريه التركيه من صناديق الاقتراع على
المباشره من دون حاجه الى وسيط يتكئ عليه
ليكون رئيسا يريد ان يكون رئيسا قويا حتى
في الانتخاب وبالتالي لن يضطر الى الذهاب
نحو سنان اوغان الا اذا ارى ان الامور لن
تحسن باي حال من الاحوال الا اذا كان هناك
اصوات داعمه له حتى لو كان ذلك دكتور
فقط السؤال الجواب على سؤالك ما التقاطعات
التي بينها وبين الرئيس اردوغان ليس بينه
وبين الرئيس اردوغانم وحزب العداله
والتنميه بقدر ما هي من حزبه الام حزب
الحركه القوميه التي يمكن ان يجدوا لها
لها صيغه معينه لتحويل اصواتهم اذا ما
ارتقى الرئيس اردوغان بانها
الحل الوحيد الاوحد خليني اسال فقط حضرتك
تشكك ان كان اردوغان سيعتمد على هذه
الوساطه او لا اسالك سيد جواد
وباختصار ان تكرمت حضرتك قريب من شخص وقلت
حتى تحدث حتى عن قرابه بينكما تتحدث عن
دعمه لاردوغان عن قراءه عن يعني طريقه
فهمت بها هذا الشخص ام ان هناك فعلا حديث
عن انه سيتوجه لدعم اردوغان
فهو يريد ان يقترب من اردوغان لكن هنا
مشكله اساسيه لا يعرف احد يعني ليس
متداولا في الاعلام ان حليف
اردوغان فهو دوله برخشلي من حزب الحركه
القوميه هو لا يريد سنان ابدا
لان هناك كان في حزب دوله برشلي وكان
منافسا له وكان يريد ان يسيطر على الحزب
وطردوه من حزب الحركه القوميه فهو اتفق مع
تحالف الاجداد وغير ذلك يعني عندما هو
يريد ان يقترب من اردوغان ولربما هو يمانع
اردوغان ان يقبله هذا اولا وثانيا انه في
هذه المرحله الان تبدا التفاوضات من شخصيه
كمال كلش نعرف ان هذا الشخص شخص يعني لا
يصرح تصريحات ناريه ضد احد واللسانه لسانه
لين جدا
فهذا يقدر ان يجذب سنان اوغان بشكل او اخر
لكن المشكله الاساسيه
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه اعلنوا الدعم
لكم والكل يعرف ذلك انهما متفقان الان
سنان اوغان واتباعه قوميين متشددين جدا هل
هؤلاء سوف يقبلون كمال كردستان اتفاقه معك
سنان اوغن علما ان ورائهم حزب شعوب
الديمقراطيه هنا المشكله الاساسيه لننتظر
لقاءات ومفاوضات بين الجانبين حتى اسبوعان
سيكونان يعني اسبوعان مليان بالحوارات مده
طويله في السياسه طبعا خاصه واننا نتحدث
عن جوله ثانيه مفصليه ولكن اسمحوا لي ان
نشرك كذلك معنا العين الخارجيه من باريس
وكذلك من واشنطن واسمحوا لي ان ابدا معك
دكتور وليد دكتور وليد تعلم حضرتك بانه في
كل الانتخابات
النسبه الثالثه او المرتبه ستكون جدا مهمه
لانه في جوله ثانيه يعول عليها للدفع باحد
المرشحين هل تعتقد بانه هذه النسبه ستكون
مفتاح الجوله الثانيه
طبعا من واشنطن ليس هنالك موقف رسمي
اطلاقا فيما يتعلق بهذا الموضوع لاوضح هذا
هنالك اراء وهنالك تحاليل وهنالك مراكز
ابحاث تراقب متى يجري
والشيء يعني الاستثنائي في هذه الانتخابات
انها تظهر بوضوح على شاشات التلفزه
الامريكيه بعكس انتخابات اخرى في مناطق
اخرى وهنالك اهتمام كبير فيها وبالتالي ما
نراه على شاشه التلفزه او نقراه او
التقارير التي تاتي من تركيا تضهر بوضوح
ان هنالك كتلتين كتله اقرب يعني الرئيس
اردوغان اقرب الى الرقم المطلوب وكتله
اخرى لديها القدره لديها القدره وكما
سمعنا من المحللين الكرام هنالك مشكله
تحالف ضمن هذه الكتله وهذا سوف يقرر يعني
امكانيه وصول المعارضه رقميا موجود ولكن
سياسيا يعني هنالك صعوبات كبرى اذا استمرت
الارقام للرئيس اردوغان لم يعد لديه الا
ان يكسب القليل وقد يكسبها من الطرفين
الاصغر في الحروف عندها قد يكون هو الرئيس
القادم اما اذا حصل هنالك تفاهم كما قال
المحللون الكرام يعني هذا قد يصنع من كتله
قويه قد هي تحصل على بعض الارقام من حزب
اردوغان ويمكنها ولو افترضنا عشرين او 25%
من الحظوظ ان تربح الانتخابات وماذا عن
الغرب الدكتور خلدون الغرب الذي يتهمه
اردوغان بانه يدعم كلتشدار اوغلو هذا اولا
وثانيا حضرتك تعلم بانه الجوله الاولى كنا
تحدثنا فيها عن جوله صعبه للطرفين في
الواقع ولكن يبدو بانه من خلال على الاقل
ما نستمع له معكم بان الجوله الثانيه قد
تكون اصعب قراءه حضرتك فيما يخص المنتظر
من هذه الجوله
اهلا بك يا ريم اهلا فيك الاعزاء وبمشاهدي
قناه العربيه يعني الغرب
كعادته هو يعني يفتخر بالنموذج الديمقراطي
جدا ان هناك انتخابات في بلد اخر ليس عليه
التدخل فيها بشكل رسمي وبالتالي هو يحاول
ان يظل على الحياد لكن بنفس الوقت هناك
يعني امكانيه لتحركات غير رسميه لا شك ان
اوروبا عموما وبخاصه فرنسا على سبيل
المثال بريطانيا ايضا لا تفضل بقاء يعني
رجب طيب اردوغان في السلطه كان هناك توتر
كبير ما بين اردوغان والاوروبيين عموما
سواء في اليونان سواء في قبرص وبخاصه مع
يعني الرئيس الفرنسي ماكرون ووصل الامر
الى حد يعني تبادل التلاسم حتى والشتائم
احيانا واتهام كل شخص للاخر يعني بطريقه
غير دبلوماسيه وبالتالي الغرب ليس ليس
يعني لا يفضل بقاء من يسميه بالرجل
الاسلام السياسي رجل الدوله العثمانيه
يفضل عليه دون شك التقاليد الاتتركيه
الغربيه او المتاربه اذا صحت التسميه يفضل
عليه دون شك كمان
ولكن ماذا بامكان الغرب سواء الاوروبي او
الامريكي ان يفعل يعني سمعنا تصريح الرئيس
الامريكي
بايدن ليفوز من يفوز المنطقه مليئه
بالمشاكل هناك ولكن يعني هذا التصريح الذي
يبدو غير مبالي ايضا اظن انه يعكس يعني او
يخفي بالاحرى عدم رغبه على الاقل
الديمقراطيين في امريكا بفوز اردوغان يعني
جاء بيض الى السلطه وهو يحمل خطابا ضد
اردوغان لكن السياسه الخارجيه التي على ما
يبدو ار اجاد اللعب فيها سواء مع اوروبا
سواء مع امريكا وحتى التفافاته السياسيه
وتغيير لمواقفه ومحاوله التصالح وتهدئه
الكثير من الجبهات يعني جعل له اليد طولها
وبخاصه لو اخذنا بعين الاعتبار القضيه
الاكثر يعني بروزا على الساحه الان وهي
الحرب الاوكرانيه وموقف الغرب غير الراضي
عن موقف اردوغان الذي رفض العقوبات على
على روسيا الذي لم يعني يبدو بشكل واضح
انه لا يصطف مع الناتو في في الحرب في
اوكرانيا يعني هو هناك تبادلات تجاريه
كبيره ازدادت بعض الحرب بين روسيا وتركيا
وبالتالي هناك الكثير من القضايا التي
تجعل اوروبا على خلاف المانيا التي يبدو
انها بسبب وجود الكثير من الاتراك يعني
على ارضها تظل حذره في في هذا الموضوع لكن
لو سمحتي لي ريم فقط يعني هناك
وبسرعه يعني
يعني شيء لم يتم الحديث عنه وقد يكون اهم
بالنسبه للمرشحين من سنان وجان وهو نسبه
العشره بالمئه التي لم تصوت وهي اكثر من
10% بالقليل يعني 10% يمكن في حال قام كل
طرف بمحاوله
اغراء اولئك الصامتون الذين لم يصوتوا
للان هناك نسبه 10% طبعا لا شك ان هناك
خمسه بالمئه فاصله اثنان عند سنان اوغان
ولكن هناك الفئه الصامته التي لم تذهب
والذي يمكن ان تتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع
لحسم الجوله القادمه اذا هناك مهمه كبيره
تقع على الطرفان الان في الدعايه
الانتخابيه الجديده لكلا الطرفان
وربما وهي الكلمه الاخيره الان
يعني اميل الى الاعتقاد بان سنان وجان قد
يميل الى اردوغان لان النتيجه
يعني اقرب الى اردوغان هناك مهمه صعبه
كبيره على المعارضه بقياده كمال
ولكنها صحيح صحيح اتيت على ذكر فقط
بالعوده تحدثت عن شان داخله ترك ولكن
قبلها كنت تحدثت عن وجهات النظر الاوروبيه
الامريكيه الروسيه فقط تسمحوا لي ضيوف
الكرام ان نذكر ببعض مقاله اولا الجانب
الامريكي بايدن رئيس الامريكي وكذلك
وهو المعني كما تفضلت بالاشاره دكتور
خلدون
هذا مقاله بخصوص انتظارات روسيا من هذه
الانتخابات نتابع ومن ثم نعود
الانتخابات التركيه التعليق الروسي
والامريكي
الكرملين التعاون مع تركيا سيستمر بغض
النظر عن الفائز بالانتخابات بايدن
وبتصريح مقتضب ليفوز من يفوز
يؤثر على الداخل التركي من حيث التصويت
بمعنى انه هذه التصريحات الاكيد بانها في
الظاهر تصريحات
المراد منها بانها غير معنيه تماما ولكن
الحسابات تعلم حضرتك بانه تضع هذه الدول
في متابعه لصيقه لنتائج هذه الانتخابات
لان تركيا مهمه في المنطقه وفي العالم
كذلك فهل تعتقد بان هذه الملفات قادره على
التاثير على الناخب التركي
العلم السياسي يقول لنا ان السياسه
الخارجيه مؤثره بالداخليه والعكس صحيح
وبالتالي مواقف الدول الخارجيه من هذه
الانتخابات ومهمه ومهم للغايه ربما كانت
الدول الاوروبيه والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
تماطلان في الكثير من الملفات مع تركيا
الى موعد الانتخابات العلى او كانت تكون
انتخابات تاتي بما تريده رياحهم ولكن يبدو
انهم امام خمس سنوات ايضا صعبه
يتعبهم فيها الرئيس اردوغان من جديد تكثر
لاءاته في وجههم
يضع تركيا في استقلاليه وفي سياسه خاصه لا
تستطيع اي دوله الا ان تلعبها الا تركيا
يعني على سبيل المثال تركيا في حلف الشمال
الاطلسي تركيا تبيع المسيرات لاوكرانيا
ولكنها ترفض العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا
وتستوسع شراكاتها مع
لانها كذلك لانها فقدت دكتور مهند لانها
تبيع نفس هذه المسيرات بمقدار لروسيا كذلك
بغض النظر ولكن انت ان تكوني
تذهبين في هذا الاتجاه وايضا في نفس الوقت
تلعبين باتجاه اخر هذه السياسه خاصه في
السياسه التركيه في عهد الرئيس اردوغان
هذا ما يزعج العواصم الغربيه عموما من
واشنطن الى دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وعلى
سبيل المثال في الملفات التي ماطلت فيها
دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه هو الدخول تركيا في
هذا النادي هذا وان يكون ان يذهب الرئيس
اردوغان وياتي رئيس على قد يدهم ومن ثم
يديرونه ويدخلونها تركيا في الاتحاد
الاوروبي بما دامت الحاكميه والقياده سوف
تكون لهم من خلف ولكن يبدو انهم يعني قد
منيو ايضا
بخساره لهذه الطموحات
الانتخابات هي هي مفاجئه ولكن حضرتك تحدثت
اردوغان البعض يقول بانه في الفتره
الاخيره التي سبقت هذه الانتخابات اردوغان
صار اكثر ليونه مع مجموعه كبيره من
الملفات لم يتوقع بان يت راجع بخصوصها
نتحدث عن التقارب مع النظام السوري نتحدث
عن التقارب مع مصر نتحدث عن ملف الاخوان
وفي هذا الاطار استاذ جواد هل هذه الملفات
تعني الداخل التركي بمعنى ان عوده اردوغان
او ليونته في التعامل معها هل يمكن ان
تؤثر على من تبقى للتصويت له
طبعا قضيه سوريا يعني ملف الخارجي اكثر
شيء بشكل مباشر يؤثر الى الانتخابات قضيه
اللاجئين قضيه اللاجئين كان كانت نتاج
للسياسه الخاطئه بالنسبه الى جارتنا سوريا
ولهذا السبب سياسه الخارجيه تؤثر الى
سياسه داخليه بشكل عام انه اردوغان طبعا
في الاغذيه الاخيره قام ببعض التعديلات
وعوده العلاقات تحسين العلاقات مع بعض
الجيران هذه الجهود كانت طبعا كنا ايضا
نثمن مثلا تطبيع العلاقات مع مصر
وتحسين العلاقات مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وغير ذلك هذه خطوات ايجابيه لكن
بالنسبه الى سوريا جرح دامي يعني بحاجه
الى
يعني مداومه سريعه يعني
بالنت
نزيف تم لازال مستمر والحال في داخل تركيا
الى متى نستمر مع اللاجئين بهذا الشكل
ولهذا السبب
احد اسباب تراجع شعبيته
وازدياد القوميه فيما بين الشباب خاصه في
تركيا
قضيته قضيه اللاجئين بالنتيجه عليه ان
تعيد النظر بالنسبه الى حل هذه القضيه
وايضا ملفات الخارجيه الاخرى والا مثلا
علاقاتنا مع الاتحاد الاوروبي علاقات سيئه
جدا لابد ان يكون هناك حل لا نحتاج الى
تصريحات ناريه تجاه الجيران بشكل عام لكن
بصراحه يعني في الاذنه الاخيره القوميه
خطابات القوميه الناريه مشت مع الاسف
الشديد احد الاتهامات الى المعارضه هنا
ايضا التعاون مع الارهابيين واستنادا الى
ارهابين وغير ذلك على الحكومه التركيه ان
تقوم بخطوات
تجاه الجيران بشكل عام والا
المواطنين يعانون من مشاكل عده بالنسبه
الى دول اجنبيه دكتور
خالد
لصالح الانتخابات تتحدث عن مصر نتحدث عن
النظام السوري نتحدث حتى عن بروده في
التعامل مع ملف اللاجئين ليس هناك تحرك او
على الاقل هذا التحرك يعني تراجع في فتره
ما قبل هذا الانتخابات نتحدث كذلك حتى على
فنلندا والسويد باتت التصريحات تصريحات
الرئيس اردوغان في فتره من الفترات اكثر
ليونه وامكانيه قبول هذان البلدان في حلف
الناتو هل تعتقد بانه هذه الملفات تاتي في
اطار تغيير اردوغان لسياسه اذا ما تم
انتخابه كرئيس جديد لتركيا او انه
استخدمها فقط للانتخابات ومن ثم قادر على
العوده
يعني جزئيا نعم هناك ملفات كانت طازجه من
اجل الانتخابات ملفات اخرى كانت في محاوله
للعوده الى الساحه بقوه محاوله لاصلاح
الوضع الاقتصادي نتيجه التضخم نتيجه
ارتفاع او انخفاض سعر الليره التركيه هناك
ملفات كثيره استدار بها اردوغان في يعني
كان على علاقات متوتره
ناريه حتى سواء مصر مع دول الخليج او بعض
دول الخليج العربي مع اوروبا بشكل اساسي
وبخاصه مع اكتشاف الغاز في حوض المتوسط
ومشكله الحدود المائيه الكثير من الملفات
التي ارادت تهدئه فيها الملف السوري
تحديدا ياتي ضمن ملف اللعبه الانتخابيه
بالنسبه لاردوغان اردوغان طبعا ملف
اللاجئين كان قد استخدمه عده مرات فيما
تسميه دول اوروبا بالابتزاز بملف اللاجئين
كان يهدد بفتح الح وقد فعل ذلك اكثر من
مره
او ايضا محاوله يعني وضع النوع من الفاصل
ما بين اكراد سوريا واكراد تركيا عبر
توطين اللاجئين او ما يسوونه يسميهم كذلك
لكن على المدى القريب ليس هناك امكانيه
للتفاهم المباشر ما بين انقره ودمشق يعني
وهذا ما جعل بشار الاسد يعني يطلب في
البدايه قبل ان ياتيه الاوامر الروسيه
بالتهدئه مع مع تركيا بعدم دخول في نقاش
مع مع تركيا قبل الانسحاب الكامل من
الاراضي السوريه تركيا الان ليست مستعده
لان تترك هذه الكعكه حينما بدات الامور
تتغير لا شك ان لديها مصلحه الان في في
القضيه السوريه ولكن موضوع اللاجئين موضوع
مهم جدا كان مطروح على طاوله المفاوضات
كان ورقه بيد المعارضه واراد اردوغان
تخفيف في مثل هذا الموضوع يعني ان يقول
باننا سنعيد العلاجين ولكن يعني ليس بشكل
اكراهي ليس وبالتالي ليس هناك يعني كان
يقول بانه من غير الانسان ان يتم اعاده
اللجين وبالتالي هو يلعب هذه على هذه
الورقه وحتى موضوع التجنيز تجنيس السوريين
بشكل او باخر فيما يخص موضوع الانتخابات
وبالتالي الان ايضا موضوع سنان اوغان
وطلبه بعدم التساهل في ملف اللاجئين ربما
ايضا يقدم مزيدا من التنازلات في هذا
الموضوع لكن على المدى البعيد لا اعتقد
انه في حاله قد نجح انه منفتح تماما كما
بدا على الملف التطبيع العلاقات مع دمشق
هكذا بشكل مجاني هو لديه الكثير من يعني
المصالح في سوريا ولم يتراجع بمثل هذه
سهوله وهذه الليونه التي بدات هي من اجل
الانتخابات برايي على الاقل في الملف
السوري الدكتور فارس نرى بان الملفات جدا
عديده ومعقده كذلك فيما يخص علاقه
بجيرانها وكذلك علاقه تركيا حتى بالمنطقه
بالقوه الكبيره في العالم ومن بينها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه برغم هذه
الملفات المعاقده والجد حساسه بعض كان لها
تصريح وتبعناه منذ قليل يقول فيه ليفوز من
يفوز بمعنى انه وكانه مش فارقه معاه ان
كان فاز اردوغان او كلتش دار اوغلو هذا
الظاهر
وهناك حسابات امريكيه اخرى ام حقيقه تركيا
لا تاتي في اولويات الاداره الامريكيه
لو سمحتي لي ان اقوم بسرعه بجوله اشرح
تقريبا ما هي المواقف العمليه لمختلف
مواقع
معسكر بعيدا يعني في هذا المعسكر هو قال
مقاله انه ننتظر الى الانتخابات ولكن تحت
موقف بيتا هنالك ثلاثه مراكز قوى هنالك
الخارجيه وهنالك الحزب الديمقراطي
متمسك بالعلاقه الامريكيه التركيه يعني
ايا يكن الرئيس الاتي ولكن عنده تقليد انه
من يحافظ على القواعد الامريكيه ومن
بامكاننا ان ننسخ معه في سوريا وفي اماكن
اخرى يجب المحافظه عليه هذا موقف ليس رسمي
ولكن تقريبا معروف من قبل المحلين وزاره
الدفاع الخارجيه قلقه الخارجيه تختلف هي
تقول انه لقد جربنا كثيرا العلاقه مع
حكومه الرئيس اردوغان لسنوات والان كما
تفضل المحللون عندكم هنالك مشكله موقف
رئيس اردوغان وحزبه من موضوع الصراع في
اوكرانيا يعني هنالك نظره في وزاره
الخارجيه انه حكومه الرئيس اردوغان تتعاطى
مع كل الاطراف المخاصمه
على الرغم من وجود تركيا في النيتو الصوت
الوحيد الذي يذهب باتجاه اخر في كل الناتو
هو هو في في انقره ثالثا الحزب الحزب
موضوع اخر الحزب الان يتاثر بالجناح
اليساري ولا يخفى على احد انه الجناح
اليساري في الحسبه الديمقراطي هو في موقع
دعم مباشر للجناح اليساري والاصلاحي حتى
القومي في السياسات التركيه اذا هم لم
يخفوا انهم يعارضون الرئيس اردوغان
ويؤيدون ولكن لا قدره لديهم ان يتدخلوا في
هذه
بالنسبه للجمهوريين مقسومين الى اثنين
الذين هم مع الشركات الكبرى التسلح الى ما
هنالك ومراكز الابحاث المحافظه هؤلاء
يفضلون اردوغان الجزء الاخر هم اكثريه في
الكونجرس من المحافظين ايضا ولكن هم يعني
يقلقون جدا من العلاقه مع الاخوان
المسلمين وكل هذه المسائل هم يعارضونها
اذا هنالك مواقف كثيره في واشنطن والموقف
الرسمي هو عندما تحصل الانتخابات سوف نحدد
موقفهم اكيد هذا بالنسبه للموقف الامريكي
ماذا عن الموقف التركي سيد جواد بمعنى انه
من انسب للا الاتراك كليتش دار اوغلو او
اردوغان في تعاملهما مع
الاداره الامريكيه اردوغان نعلم سياسته
كيتشدار اوغلو تصريحاته نفهم منها على
الاقل منطقه السياسي
سيد جواد
يبدو بان ضيفي طيب سنتوجه بنفس هذا السؤال
لك دكتور مهند تفضل
يعني على الاقل الرئيس اردوغان له شخصيه
مستقله ويريد ان يجعل من تركيا ولاده
جديده في مئويتها الاولى في حين ان كمال
كريستار اولو على الاقل ان قلنا انه يحسن
التنظير هل يحسن الفعل يعني شخص لم يدر اي
مقر او اي بلديه او اي حي في اي مدينه في
اسطنبول ليس لديه خبره في اداره امور
صغيره لكي يترقى الى ان يدير دوله بحجم
تركيا بمعنى الدوله التركيه دوله ثقيله
ليست لا يعني هنا الثقل الجغرافي بقدر ما
اعني ان الثقل الملفات السياسيه
الاقتصاديه العسكريه الاقليميه كبيره جدا
الرئيس اردوغان ومنذ 20 عاما وهو يقود هذه
البلاد وهناك ملفات كان فيها بعض الاخطاء
ويعيد ويقيم في هذه السياسات لثقل هذه
الدوله فك لمثل شخصيه مثل كماله سوف يقوم
بحمل هذا الثقل كله وهو ليست لديه الخبره
اطلاقا يعني يقولون ان المشكله بعد ان
ظهرت الارقام ومني بمسافه كبيره ما بينه
وبين اردوغان يقول لك مع الاسف
لماذا اخترتموه اذا لماذا قبلتم انتم
كمعارضه بشكل عام سواء كنتم مؤيدين من
احزابه او او التابعين لاحدى الاحزاب
السته او معارضين مستقلين لماذا قبلتم بان
يكون هذا ممثلكم
بانه لم يكن في حديثهم وفي تصريحاتهم
يقولون بانه ليس لم يكن هناك بديل على كل
هو تماما
اسمح لي على المقاطعه انتهى تماما توقيت
الحلقه او شكرا اكيد باننا سنبقى في
متابعه هذه التطورات الدكتور مهند حافظ
اوغلو الباحث في شان التركي الشكر كذلك
لحضرتك جواد المحلل السياسي وشكر
لضيوفي من باريس دكتور خلدون النبواني
الباحث السياسي ومن واشنطن دكتور وليد
فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه شكرا دائما على الطبل المتابعه
والسلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات